it has come to my attention that i
forgot to acknowledge a very important
holiday yesterday
it is a holiday that commemorates the
life of one of the most important and
admired americans ever to live
a man who helped to transform our
country into the place that we live in
today
i'm speaking of course
about george floyd who joe biden
believes left a far more important
impact on our nation
than other lesser figures such as
i don't know martin luther king
but even dr king's assassination did not
have the worldwide impact
that george floyd's
death did joe biden commemorated the
life of martin luther king by discussing
how much less he meant to the world than
did an unrepentant violent career
criminal who died resisting arrest while
high on a fatal dose of drugs
and the saddest part is
he's probably right
martin luther king may have had a dream
but joe biden has a nightmare i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from tim skrobot
talking about that hostage attack in
the synagogue in texas where the muslim
terrorist held the jews captive he says
you'd think the fbi would understand a
terror plot better considering how many
they helped to facilitate hey that's not
fair they just can't comment on that you
could you shouldn't say the fbi
facilitated any attacks they just
they can't comment one way or the other
okay and that's that's their story and
they're sticking to it even before
committees of the united states senate
that's unfortunate you know it's sad
when we live in a country where we can't
trust our government where we can't
trust our rulers where we can't even
trust that the media or any any other
aspects of the ruling class to tell us
what's true and false and right and
wrong there is one little upside to
living in america right now that is that
you can get 25 cents back for every
gallon of gas on your fill up if you use
get upside are you spending too much
money on gas
yes you are i know that you are by
definition you are if you have not yet
downloaded the get upside app it is a
free app that will allow you to make up
to 25 cents cash back for every gallon
of gas every time you fill up very
simple you go to your app store you
download the free app
and then you use promo code knowles
guess what happens then not only will
you get 25 cents cash back for every
gallon you fill up
you'll get another 25 cents cash back
for every gallon you fill up on your
first tank
50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank when you use get upside and
promo code knolls some people who drive
a lot are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a year in cash back
that's a lot of money no catch only cash
back gets added right to your bank
account or if you prefer paypal or an
e-gift card for amazon and other brands
head on over right now
download the free get upside app and use
promo code nullscanwles to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank with code
knowles
joe biden says george floyd left a
greater impact on america than martin
luther king
that's probably true
that's probably true right i know that
conservatives are dunking on joe biden
right now and attacking him and how
offensive is this and how terrible
but joe biden didn't say that george
floyd was a better person than martin
luther king
he said that he left a greater impact on
the world not even just america but on
the whole wide world and that might be
true
martin luther king
did help to shape the world transformed
the world in many ways
but
but george floyd may have transformed
the world
much more
and whereas the legacy of martin luther
king is
hotly debated and the leftists try to
appropriate him and the conservatives
try to appropriate him and the democrats
try to appropriate him and the
republicans try to appropriate him and
the leftists point to the many things
that martin luther king said that
sounded sort of socialistic or sort of
leftist and the conservatives point to
the i have a dream speech in particular
where you shouldn't judge people based
on your race and
regardless of of
exactly who can grab martin luther
king's legacy they point to the i'm on
the i've been to the mountaintop speech
this kind of very deep christian
religious rhetoric that he infused in
his speeches
regardless
the blm version of america seems to be
winning right now
the blm version of america which says we
most certainly should judge people on
the basis of their race
we should
give
black people and other non-white people
special privileges we should tear down
the statues of our founding america as a
white supremacist terrible evil country
hopelessly bigoted
we've got to tear the whole thing down
the economic system the political system
and we've got to
to create a whole brand new country
that's very different than the martin
luther king vision the martin luther
king vision is america might have
problems but the the problems are only
so clear because we know the idea of
america is so wonderful and america's
not living up to her ideals and we need
to we need to fulfill the promise of the
founding fathers and george washington
and thomas jefferson and and that vision
is completely at odds regardless of of
the left or the right trying to grab
martin luther king's legacy i think we
all have to acknowledge that the blm
version of american history is
completely at odds with the martin
luther king version and the blm version
is winning right now so biden was
probably right when he said that george
floyd had a greater impact on the world
that's unfortunate but probably the case
speaking of racial politics
donald trump is back on the campaign
trail
he held a rally on january 15th
and he leaned into
a major racial issue that's going on
right now
namely
that white people are being
discriminated against when it comes to
treatment for kovid in many states as a
result of guidance issued by the
national government by the fda here's
donald trump
just denigrating white people to
determine who lives and who dies if
you're white
you don't get the vaccine or if you're
white you don't get therapeutics
it's unbelievable to think this
and nobody wants this
black people don't want it white people
don't want it nobody wants it
it's not even believable you saw this a
week ago where it came out nobody can
even believe it they don't even talk
about it and they don't want to talk
about it because they know
it doesn't work very well for them but
the wall street journal described the
practice
race-based preferential
covet treatments and that's what it is
you get it based on race
in fact in new york state if you're
white
you have to go to the back of the line
to get medical help think of it if
you're white you go right to the back of
the line
this is
really
important
for donald trump to point out that
because this is a
grievous issue that's going on in and of
itself and it's really smart politics so
what the left is trying to do now is
they're denying that what he said is
true which is why trump cites the wall
street journal very credible mainstream
news source
we covered it on this show two weeks ago
you're seeing preferential treatment for
non-white groups and you're seeing
whites discriminated against in a number
of states in part this is because the
fda has
said that there is a disparate impact
there's a disproportionate
negative effect of kovid on marginalized
communities and they define marginalized
communities as non-white communities and
so they get to go further up in the line
than the white people do this is
absolutely real it's really happening
credible credible authoritative
mainstream news sources even are
reporting on it so trump is citing that
he's saying you can't fact-check me on
this and it's it's wrong it's a it's a
wrong thing to do and people of all
races know that it's wrong so he's not
just saying that this is white grievance
and it's the white people versus the
black people or versus the hispanic
people versus the it's not
all decent people of all races can agree
that it is wrong to deny someone medical
care on the basis of their race
this is not a black and white it is a
black and white issue in as much as it's
very clear and all decent white black
asian hispanic people know that it's
it's the wrong thing to do and i think
this will play very well on the campaign
trail
but it's also and this is the part that
a lot of people are missing this is also
a really smart move from trump because
it gets him out of his toughest
political position right now namely that
he owns the vaccine issue he developed
the vaccines he has promoted the
vaccines and a lot of his base doesn't
really like the vaccines one because the
vaccines do not do all of the things
that joe biden and dr fauci and rachelle
wolenski said that they would do
biden fauci wallenski all said the
vaccines would prevent infection and
transmission of the virus and the
vaccines don't
do that so
then they changed their story and they
said well no actually the vet the
vaccines do not prevent transmission and
infection but they do mitigate the
symptoms and so they keep moving the
goalposts and keep changing their
stories and the base is highly skeptical
of that and they have some moral
objections to the vaccines and they
obviously object to the vaccine mandates
which trump has said he opposes but he's
still got to own the vaccines so how's
he going to get him at himself out of
this predicament
he can say
that the left is trying to deny you
medical care
he's saying there
the left is trying to take this good
thing away from you and so it just
softens the vaccine issue it's a
political master stroke that very few
people have picked up on but it's the
first it's the first maneuver trump has
made on this vaccine covid policy issue
in months and months and months that i
think is actually going to move the ball
in the right direction
so what's the response from
from the left the left is calling him
racist the left is denying that it's
happening the lev but
everyone sees through that this is a
really strong issue a lot of republicans
should campaign on this but but there is
still this issue of the vaccines namely
they're not as effective as we were told
they would be the latest story out of
israel israeli trial the world's first
finds fourth dose
not good enough against omicron it's
from the times of israel
fourth dose
so
so the first
two
shots not quite as effective as the
experts had hoped
then there was a third dose that was
given out
that was also i guess not quite as
effective because you need a fourth dose
then they had the fourth dose so the
fourth jab
and that was not quite as effective as
we were all told it was going to be
but i bet they'll get it right on the
fifth one
don't worry don't know the good news the
bright side is that the fifth one is
expected to be more effective than any
of them
oh okay cool
great this to talk about impossible
political problems this is a really
tricky political problem for the liberal
establishment because right now the
liberal establishment needs to sell
a huge number of people on getting the
fourth
and potentially fifth dose of this
vaccine
because the first three are not
effective against the new strain of the
virus but at the same time they've got
to convince a lot of other people who
haven't had any shots of the vaccine to
get the first and second dose of the
vaccine
but why would people get the first and
second dose if the people who got the
first and second dose need now need to
get a third and fourth and possibly
fifth dose
so you've got it you've got to convince
different groups of people in the uh uh
who have various stages of vaccination
that
the first and second dose were so
ineffective that you now need to get
three four five but also that the first
and second doses are so effective that
you'll die you're putting your whole
community at risk if you don't get the
first two
the the experts the rolling class
speaking out of both sides of their
mouths contradicting themselves and i
strongly suspect
that the people are less and less fooled
each day by it
now when you don't want to be fooled by
high prices at the auto parts store i
would strongly recommend you check out
rock auto all right i've got a
hypothetical for you let's say that you
need a new fuel pump assembly for your
car
and i give you two choices
a
is the fuel pump assembly for x amount
of money
and b
is the fuel pump assembly for
30 more than x amount of money or 50
more than x amount of money or 100 more
than x amount of money then you're going
to be paying for choice a
which one do you buy
this is not a trick question it's a very
simple question you buy the cheaper one
so why would you not be going to
rockauto.com right now where you can get
any part you want for your car or truck
for the lowest price available
you don't need to drive to the brick and
mortar store you don't need to wait in
line you don't need to wait for the guy
to go into the back to look for the part
that's probably not in stock anyway to
come back out to say they're going to
order it to wait a week to pay more
money just go to rockauto.com
super easy to use catalog reliably low
prices go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck and then write knowles in the how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you
speaking of our vaunted public health
officials
did you know that dr fauci is loaded
i think a lot of people suspected that
dr fauci was pretty well off he's a very
prominent very powerful figure in our
government
but he's been a public servant his whole
life he's worked at the nih now for 40
years almost
so you know he's a government worker he
probably shouldn't that's not how you
become a millionaire right working for
the government you do it because you
want to serve the public you do it
because you want to follow the science
if you're working at the nih and you're
a
you're a hard-working scholar but you
don't you don't go into that line of
work to get rich
but dr fauci did get rich he was asked
when he was testifying before congress
to disclose some of his the details of
his finances and dr fauci got very very
defensive
yes or no would you be willing to submit
to congress and the public a financial
disclosure that includes your past and
current investments after all your
colleague dr wilinski and every member
of congress submits a financial
disclosure that includes their
investments
and vouchers right away he goes he tries
to he's talking he tries to remove that
mask he realizes that he hasn't turned
the mic i don't understand why you're
asking me that question my financial
disclosure
is public knowledge and has been so
for the last 37 years or so 35 years
big tech giants are doing an incredible
job of keeping it from being public uh
we'll continue to look for it where
would we find it
all you have to do is ask for it
i i you're so misinformed it's
extraordinary why am i why am i most
important it is totally accessible to
you if you want it for the public is it
accessible to the public
to the public right we look forward to
our view totally incorrect we look
forward to reviewing it getting a little
defensive there huh dr fauci
what are you he's asking you a simple
question
he's saying
have you disclosed your finances and
if they're available where can i find
them
you are totally incorrect incorrect
about what he didn't make any claims he
just asked you your question is
incorrect
how can a question be incorrect it's a
simple question it's not a particularly
aggressive or offensive question it's
just hey where can i find your financial
disclosures that you're telling me that
you made
you are so misinformed yo cool it with
the insults buddy it's a
why are you getting so
defensive
because dr fauci is freaking loaded
that's why
so it's a very simple question can we
find your finances fact he says they're
all public well they're obviously not
public because we we don't have them yet
the member of congress couldn't track
them down so they're not all that public
how about you just tell us how about you
just prev no just ask st
rand paul or not
dr fauci
first started using this line when he
was speaking to rand paul you'll
remember that rand paul accused dr fauci
of funding gain of function research in
wuhan in fact she's you're completely
incorrect senator and then rand paul
comes out he says well actually we have
all of the details of you funding dr
barrack and we have the grant proposal
right here and we and then thatchy got
caught in the line he goes well yeah but
no and but you're incorrect and he just
keeps reciting this line so he's now
he's he's just saying it as a as a
matter of rote
discourse even when it doesn't make
sense for the question okay so what's
the answer to the question what are your
finances fouchy
well according to financial disclosures
obtained by open the books the federal
government paid fouchy and his wife who
also works at nih
868 thousand
eight hundred twelve dollars in combined
income and benefits last year
in addition to their federal salaries
the fouchy household
also received royalties and stipends
totaling over a hundred thousand dollars
at least 113 298 dollars
and their investment accounts increased
this is the big one
their investment accounts increased by
almost eight hundred thousand dollars
that year
a pretty good return on investment eight
hundred thousand dollars
well how'd you manage that dr fauci well
because the fouchy household net worth
is over
10.4 million dollars
wow
that's a lot of money for a civil
servant
that's a lot of money for us just a
scientist working in the lab on a
government salary 10.4 million
dollars well that his that's his wife's
salary too that has added to that
oh his wife who also is a civil servant
working for the government
10
10 over 10 million dollars huh man i'm
in the wrong line of
work i got to go work for the government
maybe i can maybe i can get me 10
million bucks
maybe it's just because dr fauci
is a very prominent
high-profile
public figure and scientists maybe made
a lot of money on speeches but maybe he
made a lot of money on i don't know some
of his scientific work maybe he's made a
lot of money on his investments
obviously maybe those investments have
something to do with his work i don't
know i'm actually not making the
accusation but i sure would like to know
the character of dr vauch's investments
don't you think that's
sort of a
a basic ask
don't you think it's pretty reasonable
to say hey dr fauci if you're in an
extremely powerful government position
you're the highest paid person in the
federal government
and you're
moving billions of dollars around and
sending billions of dollars around to
different research and different private
companies sometimes to help with that
research and you're
approving certain trials and certain
studies and and encouraging the use of
certain drugs certain drugs the patents
which are owned by certain companies and
who knows where your money's invested i
just want to know
because this seems
like a great opportunity for corruption
i'm not saying fauci has engaged in any
kind of financial corruption
it's just curious that a lifelong civil
servant would be worth 10 million bucks
just asking questions no need to get
defensive doctor you're incorrect
michael
well how am i incorrect i'm asking
questions you ain't shut up you you're
incorrect speaking of the science i have
to get to this story it's not really a
story it's more of a personal anecdote a
couple of days ago it was snowing in
nashville
and it snows in nashville a couple times
a year but it's snowing kind of shut
everything down i wasn't able to come
into the office and so i jokingly
tweeted out i said dear libs if global
warming is real why is it snowing your
is michael this is a very
simple an innocuous joke a dad joke
it's snowing therefore i don't i don't
know if i buy this global warming thing
i don't really by global warming either
but not because it's knowing we'll get
to that in a little bit in a little bit
later
i at the same time sent out this tweet i
said knowles destroys
snowflakes argument
with facts and snowflakes so i'm
making a little joke about the sometimes
sensationalist headlines that we here at
the daily wire have pioneered on on
certain arguments and debates okay
that's it i didn't i didn't think it was
the funniest joke i just thought you
know it's okay the snow is kind of
irking me i can't go to work
the libs
lost their minds over this tweet they
can't
my my phone is exploding over this tweet
because they took my
simple
overdone
joke
as
my thesis
on global warming and the scientific
establishment and so it's all of these
humorless
very self-serious liberals who are
responding now with all of their
arguments about global warming
now
one of the the fun things to do
when you make a joke about how the
world's not really going to end in 10
years
because of the sun monster or whatever
they say
is
you say look it's it's snowing
therefore global warming is not real and
then the lips get really really angry
they say no you idiot weather isn't
climate
no you idiot it was really it was really
warm on christmas day someone actually
responded to me said it was really warm
on christmas day and new year's day
and i responded to him and i said yeah
but weather isn't climate
they said but you just said but right
but but you just said
when the libs say weather isn't climate
what the reason they say that is because
some weather event or series of weather
events has contradicted their global
warming narrative
but then the minute that a weather event
or a series of weather events
seems to buttress their global warming
narrative let's say it's there's a hot
streak in the middle of the summer
they will point to that and they'll say
this is evidence of global warming so
it's it's completely disingenuous when
the limbs do it because when weather
when weather is cold
that's that's not
weather isn't climate and when weather
is hot
that is
climate and that is evidence of global
warming so anyway it's a little funny
silly little game
the only reason i bring this up
is because uh not because of global
warming or whatever the reasons to be
skeptical of global warming is because
major apocalyptic scientific predictions
that have been made even within just the
last 50 years have all turned out to be
completely bogus namely global cooling
which was a very serious scientific
thesis in the 1970s and it turned out to
be at at best
the opposite of true
because now they're all pushing global
warming overpopulation paul ehrlich a
fetid scientist uh still remains a
lauded scientist on the left he said
that within 10 years of 1970 there would
be mass famines because of
overpopulation we needed more
contraception we needed abortion we need
to coerce contraception and abortion if
need be
and even then it wouldn't stop the
famines but it might mitigate it a
little bit so these policies were
adopted in india in china
sterilizing poor people
killing babies horrific genocide is what
resulted from this nevertheless the
global population doubled malnutritions
at an all-time low so the reason i'm
skeptical of the doomsday predictions
the world's going to end in 12 years is
because none of that ever comes true and
it's just preposterous but
the reason i bring up the story is
actually nothing to do with global
warming or climate change or whatever
it's that the left
has no idea what we think
the left really believes that the
right-wing skepticism of the global
warming apocalypse amounts to duh it's
snowing outside no global warming they
think they think that a simple joke that
we're making is our actual argument
because they probably don't know very
many conservatives if any and the only
understanding they have of the
conservative point of view is some
caricature that they're given on cnn and
msnbc
very sad for them they don't know what
we're talking about
now
one thing i'm very excited about is this
new daily wire movie that's coming out
that would be shut in
we are releasing
the final trailer for the daily wires
first original production shut in it's a
seat gripping thriller that will be able
to stream in early february the film
follows the story of a young mother
who's barricaded inside a closet by her
violent ex-husband as she's trapped
inside she uses nothing but her voice to
guide her children on the other side of
the walls to safety all while the threat
for dangerous ex looms take a look
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
i'm scared
spooky go to shutinfilm.com to watch the
full trailer and get ready for the
film's release on february 10th the film
is exclusive to the daily wire so make
sure you head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe also join me ben shapiro
jeremy boring matt walsh and andrew
klavan tonight 7 o'clock p.m eastern 6
p.m central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel dailywire
we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show speaking of not
understanding what the other side is
saying in politics
planned parenthood
made a very silly claim
on social media over the weekend
and it went viral and conservatives all
were totally dunking on it because it
seemed contradictory they they tweeted
out quote
sexually speaking
folks with a vulva are far more than
reproductive machines
folks with a vulva
hey
hey honey you're one of my favorite
folks for the vulva i just love you
isn't that that doesn't sound very
romantic or personal or
very polite at all
a lot of conservatives were dunking on
this because
it seems as though planned parenthood is
doing the thing it says not to do
they're saying don't just define women
by their reproductive parts don't just
say they're reproductive machines
but we're not going to call them women
we're going to call them folks with a
vulva so we're defining them by their
genitals and and the conservatives are
pointing out you hypocrites you're
contradicting yourselves but they're
actually not they're not contradicting
themselves they're making exactly the
point they want to make they attach to
it this article
which is from
wellandgood.com
and it's about the full anatomy of a
female pleasure part and how it was only
mapped in our lifetimes and here's why
knowing that matters and it talks about
sex positivity and all the good
good physical sensations that ladies can
have
planned parenthood when they
define women as folks with a vulva
are not defining them as reproductive
machines
they're defining them as pleasure
machines
right it's not
the organ that they're referencing is
not exactly a reproductive organ they're
not saying folks with ovaries they're
not saying folks with fallopian tubes
they're saying folks with
the external organs organs more
associated with pleasure than with
reproduction
they're defining women as sterile
pleasure machines they're saying women
don't need to just be
in the business of making babies
they can also be used for your sexual
gratification men and for their own
sexual ratification just their their own
pleasure but without having to worry
about the product of that love between
the man and the woman
they're using this term in part because
they want to be inclusive of women who
think that they're men of they call it
transgender men and so they don't the
transgender men don't want to be called
women even though they are women so
they're defining them by this physical
part but that's actually part of the
same issue which is that you're defining
men and women only by their most
superficial shallow skin-deep
characteristics not the deeper aspects
of their spirit and even physically the
deeper aspects of their body such as
their ovaries such as the babies that
they can produce the life that is
nurtured within them and then propagates
the human race
this is how the left
views men and women
not as
spiritually significant vessels who
who extend the human race
from generation to generation through
their love which they transmit one to
another and then out through
the successive generations but as
atomized individual
sterile pleasure machines
so
planned parenthood thinks that women are
machines just as much as
their fantasies of the handmaid's tale
of what they think that conservatives
believe even though conservatives don't
actually believe it that women are just
there to be baby-making factories just
the idea of human beings as machines
is part of the leftist modern
ugly view of human beings conservatives
view human beings as more than just
machines
as part spirit as eternal creatures that
we'll have a life on earth and will have
a life beyond earth and who are who are
answerable not merely to our own
titillating sexual pleasures you know
poke this spot and you'll you'll get a
little thrill but as
as
spiritual beings who are beholden to a
real moral order you gotta you gotta
give
planned
parenthood the credit for being coherent
within their own completely absurd
understanding of human nature speaking
of girls
christie gnome
has she's the governor of south dakota
she clearly wants to run for president
in 2024
she has a new campaign ad out
buffing up her conservative bona fides
saying she's always stood up for girls
she's never backed down on protecting
our girls on protecting our girls in
school specifically and specifically
protecting women's sports
in south dakota only girls play girls
sports why because of governor christie
gnome's leadership gnome has been
protecting girls sports for years and
never backed down gnome study
conservative leadership doesn't win
headlines it wins results now governor
gnome has a bill that will give south
dakota the strongest law in the nation
protecting female sports doing the work
delivering results governor christie
gnome text kristy to 21225 to learn more
this is complete gaslighting this is
just a complete lie
that
christie gnome and her political machine
are trying to put out there to to
backtrack from her biggest political
misstep yet
namely that christinome did back down
when it came to defending girls sports
what happened was christie gnome
was given a bill to defend girls sports
and to prevent men from competing in
girls sports by her legislature and she
said she was really excited to sign it
and then she backed down and she said
she wasn't she wasn't going to sign the
bill as is
why did this happen i don't know many
people suspect she got a call from her
corporate
donors
and from powerful national interests and
they said don't do this or you're going
to lose money for your state or you're
going to lose this event or you're going
to lose that and so she backed down
she said okay well we'll protect some
girls sports but we're going to let
dudes compete against the women in the
at the collegiate level let's say then
she reversed course because there was a
huge backlash and now she's trying to
run for president as a conservative so
she's just lying about the whole thing
i'm glad that she reversed course i'm
glad that christy gnome realized that
she was wrong and changed it
i credit her for that i would not be
going after her if she had just done
that and left it alone people make
mistakes i want people to go from being
wrong to being right and i don't want to
punish them for changing their mind in
the right direction but i really don't
like being lied to and i don't like
being lied to by democrat politicians
and i really don't like being lied to by
republican politicians and what
christinome is doing right here is lying
to us
and trying to pretend that history is
different than it was and her record is
different than it was and that makes me
even less likely to trust her
i was already skeptical of trusting her
because she was wrong on a very basic
issue namely are men women and women men
but then i said okay fine she's come
along at least but now she's lying to me
so now i have really no reason to trust
her the only reason that anyone even
started talking about this woman as a
potential presidential candidate is
because she stood firm during kovid and
didn't lock down her state that was the
reputation she got at least but my
friend john schweppe from the american
principles project i think was the first
to dig up the fact that
christy gnome actually
did not
originally stand firm against the
lockdowns it was the south dakota
legislature that stood firm against the
lockdowns christine was inclined to
institute certain lockdown measures in
her state but the legislators prevented
her from doing that as even she admits
we will be using appropriate enforcement
measures as necessary that i do have at
my disposal but we have not run into an
incidence yet where that's been
necessary
i think the question was who
specifically would enact that
enforcement
it would be it's in my executive order
so i would expect that if there's
enforcement action to be taken it would
be mine
and the follow-up then what's the
penalty for someone in lincoln or
minnehaha county who is over 65 who has
a chronic illness or doesn't comply we
will deal with that when it is necessary
we did have a bill that came before the
legislature last week
that we talked about some enforcement
mechanisms we wanted to give to the
secretary of the department of health
the legislature did not support that
bill
therefore that is not a tool that we
have available to us
today a lot of people haven't heard that
clip but that what she says there right
at the end is crucial she says look we
had a bill go up before the legislature
to try to give us
us the people who want to enforce the
mandates
the ability to enforce certain lockdown
measures
it was going to give the secretary of
health special powers to do that but
unfortunately the legislature shot it
down so we she's putting herself on the
side of the people who would enforce the
lockdown measures not the people who are
opposing the lockdown measures like some
republican governors have done but she
says no we yeah we wanted to be able to
institute those lockdown measures
but the legislature wouldn't let us
drats
so christy gnome is a moderate
republican
at best
okay and her two achievements that she's
touting one that she didn't lock down
her state and two that she defended
girls sports she did reluctantly she was
dragged kicking and screaming into those
positions so
she's a moderate republican at best and
yet she is trying to reposition herself
as a conservative what does this mean
what does it mean for christy gnome
i don't really care i'm not that
interested in christina's personal
political career
i wish her the best you know go with god
have a good life
what does it mean for the conservative
movement that interests me much more
because what it means is looking ahead
to 2022 and then especially to 2024
the candidates who want to be taken
seriously
are going to have to adopt
rather right-wing rather conservative
positions
culturally conservative positions not
even just cut taxes and leave me alone
culturally conservative we're going to
stop woke corporations from enforcing
certain measures we're going to we're
going to keep your churches open we're
going to resist the scientific genius
experts we're going to resist the
administrative government you know
strong
conservative
positions even if they don't
believe it as one wonders about
christine does she really believe these
conservative positions she's now
espousing
whether she does or not i don't really
care the fact that that's where the
pressure is is very good news for the
republican party and the conservative
movement the days of the just cut taxes
gop are over
they're over
not because the conservatives have gone
crazy and we've got lost our minds and
we're running into this radicalism
the reason that the gop is leaning more
into cultural issues right now
is because the liberals are making our
kids chant prayers to aztec human
sacrifice demons in school
i'm not speaking metaphorically here
that's not hyperbole it's not an
exaggeration
the libs
are actually making our children
chant prayers to aztec
cannibal demons
in public schools
or at least they were until
the state of california stopped doing it
following a lawsuit from parents the
state of california has permanently
removed what is called the in lock ech
affirmation from the state curriculum
the in-lock affirmation forced students
to chant prayers to the aztec demon of
human sacrifice to become warriors for
social justice
what michael surely you're making this
up i'm not i'm not reality is stranger
than fiction these days the demon that
they were chanting to is tezcat lepoka
he is the aztec demon of human sacrifice
and cannibalism among other things this
was part of the mandatory new ethnic
studies curriculum now it starts to make
a little bit more sense
because the ethnic studies curriculum
pushes this idea that
white christians bad
every other racial and religious group
good
white christians
are accused in this curriculum of
committing theocide
killing god or a god
against the indigenous peoples murdering
their gods and replacing them with the
true god the god of the bible
and in fairness to the ethnic studies
curriculum that is what happened
christian civilization came to the new
world
hernan cortez specifically arrived and
discovered the aztec empire
and he
conquered it
and he banished their the demons that
they were worshiping and he brought
christianity to that place and that is
one of the greatest political
achievements in the history of the world
the aztec empire is one of the most evil
political bodies that has ever existed
they would regularly sacrifice
all sorts of humans by ripping out their
hearts they're still beating hearts from
their chests and then kicking them down
one of their
their pyramids one of their pyramid-like
structures at the consecration of the
temple of tenochtitlan an estimated 80
000 people were sacrificed in this way
in the course of four days
the aztecs believed that the sacrifice
of innocent children in particular was
pleasing to the demons that they
worshiped and would give them more rain
for their crops and so they would
sacrifice the children they believed
that the tears of little children
were particularly pleasing and so they
would make sure to torture the children
in the most heinous ways that we
have
detailed accounts of that i'm not going
to recount for you on this show because
they're so horrifying you won't sleep at
night
that's what they did
on mass by the tens of thousands
to appease the demons that the liberals
wanted your children to pray to because
of how
awful christian civilization is
does that
does that make a lot of sense to you
no it doesn't reasonable people all
agree
that our kids should not be chanting
prayers to
human sacrifice demons
we all agree on that
i think most liberals and conservatives
we all agree on that so why
why why is it wrong why do we agree that
kids shouldn't be doing them who's to
say who's to say that one god is better
than any other god who's to say that one
religion is better than any other
religion you're delving into some pretty
murky territory here buster what
happened to the separation of church and
state what's so bad about chanting to
the the demon god if we're also going to
teach certain principles that come from
the bible are you are you seriously
telling me you're going to privilege
christianity over over the demon worship
in
in the new world
what does that imply if we are willing
to do that
there's a big political fight going on
in a maryland school district
conservative maryland school district
carroll county
it's divided on a question of whether or
not we should kick politics out of the
classroom
the policy was proposed in july of last
year
it would revise an existing rule on
employee political activities by saying
that carroll county public school staff
should avoid discussion of political
issues parties and candidates during
classroom instruction unless those
discussions align with the approved
curriculum
and this is being pushed by
conservatives to
stop the left from trying to
indoctrinate kids into radicalism and
have them enchant to aztec demons
this is a bad idea
this is a bad idea because it's based on
a faulty premise that there's such a
thing as neutrality
especially neutrality and education
there is no such thing there is no
neutrality
if you teach kids to
worship the aztec demon
you are implicitly at least sometimes
explicitly teaching them
not to worship god
if you're teaching them that human
sacrifice is good which is implicit in
prayer praying to the aztec demon god
then you are teaching them
that
stopping human sacrifice as the god of
the bible demands
is
bad
if you were teaching them
that it is good
to follow one heinous code of
morality
then you are telling them that it is bad
to follow the good true code of morality
you can't
just remain neutral on everything this
issue came up because another state
legislator got in trouble for saying
that we need to remain neutral on
teaching communism and fascism and
nazism
we need to remain neutral we can't we
can't look some people have different
views
of
hitler some people have different views
of stalin
and so we have to remain perfectly
neutral and present both sides but you
can't do that that's not how education
works education requires people to be to
to form their views to form their ideas
to form their behaviors to form their
understanding of morality and that
requires teaching people
the difference between true and false
yes and good and bad and right and wrong
if it's wrong to pray to the aztec demon
god then what god should we pray to
that's that is
the inevitable next question in
education there's no neutrality you see
it in microsoft right now
getting out of schools for a second
microsoft
has implemented a new woke word checker
this is this is in a new menu item
called grammar and refinements
in word which is
the most popular word processing program
in the world
it doesn't check how you spell words it
doesn't check how you use grammar
or punctuation it checks age bias
cultural bias ethnic slurs gender bias
gender neutral pronouns gender specific
language racial bias sexual orientation
bias and socioeconomic bias so if you
type in
mrs thatcher
referring to the iron lady mrs thatcher
did this in great britain
it will suggest that you change it to ms
thatcher
i suspect maggie thatcher is rolling in
her grave at the very thought
if you type in
the
phrase uttered by neil armstrong as he
took the first step onto the moon
one small step for a man one giant leap
for mankind it will suggest you change
it to humankind
you know humankind it's more inclusive
isn't it even though man is a
gender-neutral word in the beginning god
created man both male and female he
created them
no can't do that anymore we have to
change the first words on the moon
when you switch this tool on
the spelling mistakes are underlined in
red the grammar errors are underlined in
blue
and inclusiveness issues are underlined
in purple
microsoft is a very woke company you
might remember some months ago microsoft
held a conference and they opened the
conference by by engaging in the liberal
liturgy of
of pretty much any woke trope you can
find they threw in everything but the
kitchen sink
hello
and welcome to microsoft ignite we've
got a big day ahead and lots in store
for you
first we want to acknowledge that the
land where the microsoft campus is
situated was traditionally occupied by
the sammamish the duwamish the
snoqualmie the sukwamish the muckleshoot
the snohomish the tulalip and other
coast salish peoples since time
immemorial a people that are still here
continuing to honor and bring to light
their ancient heritage
my name is allison wines i'm a senior
program manager in our developer tools
division i'm an asian white female with
dark brown hair wearing a red sleeveless
top and i'm seth juarez program manager
of the ai platform group i'm a tall
hispanic male wearing a blue shirt khaki
pants
it goes on and on it really only gets
worse from there
slight side note you notice they never
ask themselves why this land was
occupied by all those groups of people
this land was occupied by the swamish
and the sashimi and the muckleshoot and
the hooky hockey and they all it was all
occupied by all of you why
why was that is it because one group
took it from another group
well they were all occupying it at the
exact same time i don't think so i think
actually one group came in and took the
land from the group was there that was
there before and that was considered
perfectly fine and we have no problem
with it but then we came in and took the
land in some cases won it through
conquest sometimes bought it but that's
evil and terrible because it was
christendom that came in and did that
a digression
this is
a great threat to our political order
but it's not government people pushing
it it's not just big government
all right it's
corporation it's corporate power it's
technological power
it's not government but it's still
political
it still shapes our whole political
order how we understand ourselves how we
understand our relation to citizens how
we understand our relation to the state
this happens to be the subject of my
book speechless which i finished one
year ago today exactly
and thank you to everyone who bought
that made it a number one national
bestseller this is what republicans and
conservatives are going to need to fight
moving forward
this is not just about what big
government does
but it is political it's not just about
joe biden issuing some policy raising
taxes some executive order it's it's
about joe biden redefining martin luther
king day as george floyd day which is
essentially what he did it's about some
what corporation
encouraging you to say this and don't
say this it's about big tech explicitly
prohibiting you from saying certain
things and that reshapes all of it those
are very powerful political interests
and it is incumbent on any serious
conservative who wants to maintain
something resembling the traditional
american way of life to fight back
against all of it i'm michael knowles
the michael knowles show see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show